all right eli
eli uh where'd you grow up where are you
from upstate new york
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents no
no my mom left when i was four months
old my dad raised me where'd your mom
leave
i don't know
nobody would ever say
um
but my dad was cool
that's great
and tell me about
[Music]
how you grew up any any traumatic events
or i mean how would you describe your
childhood
believe it or not it wasn't bad
you know my dad passed away when i was
17.
and um
i went in the military after that but
being a kid growing up it wasn't bad
until i got into the dope
and
that kind of screwed everything down did
you serve or i mean was it was there war
or just you were just i i was at the end
of vietnam okay
yeah i was in um 76 bravo 10 storage
supply did you go
i was in germany in germany yeah sure
and uh
drugs got introduced to you how
my niece
my niece i started sticking a needle in
my arm at 13. that was that right yes
sir so yeah
you know heroin i i tried it i didn't
like it
my my my drug of choice is meth
i like math um i'm an ex junkie but i
still smoke every day
were they calling it crystal meth back
then
what were they calling it no we used to
call it paste back then
that's when the stuff was really good
okay that was the real stuff that's when
it was made with propanol no garbage in
it no no no no garbage
and how is it different today than it
was back then
that was probably the what 60s 70s in
the 70s um
now with the dope you got to you got to
constantly do it
back then you did
you did a dime you were up for five days
oh is that right oh yeah you know it's
totally different dope then
it's funny
the prices have uh
how is the price changed believe it or
not it's about the same is it it really
is it's about the same but this stuff
here's got garbage in it yeah a lot of
it yeah a lot of it's got garbage
yeah all the drugs have garbage yeah
back when i was doing it
we didn't know what these bowls were
that you they're smoking out of now
either you snorted or you shot it
you know it was as simple as that
them were the fun days yeah okay
you've been in love before huh you've
been in love before have i been in love
before yeah
yeah yeah
yeah my son oh that's great my son did
you raise him yeah
yeah man his mom
me and her lasted about 20 years and we
just
we fell apart
and my son
stayed on my side
and then for some reason
10 years ago he didn't want to be here
anymore
what do you mean he killed himself
and you sent me a suicide he pulled his
truck into the garage and sealed all the
doors and windows and left it running
yeah at 36 36 years old
and he he was a cop
um
he was going through a lot
and to be honest i just think he got
tired of life
being a cop snow party it is he was a
deputy sheriff you know and
he he was married for a year and he has
caught his old lady screwing his best
friend
you know he was building a house that
was just
out of his price range
and
i just i honestly think the kid just
gave up
you know
that was
that was my best friend
and
that's what put me back out here it's
heartbreaking two weeks after my son
two months after my son killed himself i
had a i had a heart attack and i took
the vision in my left eye i used to be
an over-the-road truck driver
and um
there went my job so i just
said to hell with it and this is where
i'm at
and the drug use
escalating
every day
you know i get social security
um
ninety percent of it goes to dope
and that wasn't the case before your son
that wasn't the case before your son
killed him
you know i still got high
without him knowing it being a driver
and everything you know just to stay
awake right but not like i do now no now
you're a hardcore no i'm a hardcore
addict yup you've been homeless for how
long
wow
well i never even thought about it eight
and a half years
and you've been in los angeles for how
long um three now three years yeah
what made you come out that way
a change of the east coast
to get away from the riffraff back there
and it ain't much better here
it's a different flavor of refresh yes
yeah yeah it really is it's probably
just as bad though it is
it is but you know
i might be a dope addict and everything
else
but now the only care i've got
is me
i don't have to worry about anybody else
just just me is there something
nice about having so little
responsibility
a lot of pressure taken off yes i mean a
lot of pressure yeah you don't have to
worry about taking care of your son or
your wife or your kids or anything
i don't have to worry about paying bills
i don't have to worry about answering to
anybody but me insurance rent right
nothing taxes nothing
yeah
what's your what's your only concern in
the morning
my concern in the morning it's getting
well
no where am i going to get high that's
what i mean yeah
okay
yeah a lot of people call it i'm used to
somebody on heroin calling it
but yeah you know i i go to sleep with i
wake up with it yeah the math is just
it it just
you're not you're not passed out you're
not act uh don't take me wrong there's
some people out there that act really
stupid on this
but with me it's
it's how i function every day
i i don't i don't change
you know this is the way i am
you know i don't
i guess you call it tweaking i don't go
dumpster diving or anything like that it
just
it gets me through my day
you know
is it the right way to go no
is there a better way probably but i
don't want it
i i'm happy just the way i am
you know your friends here on the street
just
people that i i don't have no friends i
just have people that i know yeah i
don't i don't have friends and i don't
trust people
you know
that's the best way to do it out here
do you think you'll be down here the
rest of your life
are scared well or just homeless yes yes
yes maybe not skid row but yeah
maybe not i'm i'm thought about maybe
going up seeing san francisco for a
little while yeah i mean there's other
communities like this that are yeah
probably less
am i going to be homeless just my life
yes
because i can't afford two things i
can't afford my dope and i can't afford
a place to live at the same time
and i'd rather have the dope
you know
what's your biggest regret
losing my son yeah
losing my son do you feel
there's anything you could have done
about it
just sit there and talk to my son i like
me and me and you talking
you would have never known anything
wrong with that kid
no he was the most easiest going person
that you've ever wanted to meet um
real friendly
he came over new year's and seen me
and um
he left about one
and he was building his new home and i
told him i'd be over in the morning
to up and hang sheetrock
and he walked out the door
that was it
and i found him the next morning
how recently had he discovered his wife
with his friend
again how recently had he discovered his
wife
and and his friend together
before he killed himself
me and him were friends ever no but no
how recently had he discovered his wife
cheating oh oh i'm sorry i misunderstood
what you were saying about nine months
about nine months
i think that kind of pushed him over the
edge
yeah
as i said he was a he was a really
easygoing kid
and when he caught him he just called me
up and told me what was going on
and i told him i'd be home
and we had a few drinks together
and he just oh well
you know
i
as i said you know that that was that
was my best kit that was my best friend
and he didn't even leave a note
yeah it makes you wonder exactly what
what drove him to do it
because he he wasn't in the drugs he
wasn't into drinking
he just
took the truck home pulled it in the
garage
but they say somebody's gonna kill
themself
it takes nine seconds
to make up their mind
yeah wow that's so sad
hmm
he wasn't doing drugs no
no drugs just just
wow that's heavy
how do you think this life living on the
streets has affected your
who you are
has it changed you
yeah
yeah it has
it has um
when i had a life i trusted people
i had friends
you know
now
no
yeah you've been living in a snake pit
this is nothing but a snake pit you know
everybody's out to get what they can for
themselves
you know
it's not a fair world
but it's what you make of it
could i change it yeah
yeah but am i gonna no
i don't want to
what are you afraid of
tomorrow
i guess that's my best thing tomorrow
and eli what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life the most important lesson
wow
don't love
all it does is hurt
don't love nobody
all it does is hurt
yeah that's an interesting one
that's
that's the best answer i can give you
don't no don't love nobody
you don't get over that very easily no
no you know it's just
your heart your heart gets broken in
ways you can never you put everything
into somebody
you guys are close too right yeah oh my
god we went gambling together we went
harley in together
everything you know
when i was home from driving i'd go out
in this car with him at night
and said he was your best friend yeah
yeah we went fishing together
you pour everything that you've got into
something or someone
and then they either walk away or they
die
it leaves
it doesn't just leave a hole in your
heart
it leaves your soul empty
you know
there's no getting it back
no yeah especially that way yeah it
wasn't like he died in an auto accident
no that was just random and tragic but
but random yeah but when you kill
yourself
and you don't leave a note
you know
you have to wonder what what you did
wrong for two years i hated god i hated
god for two years
and then i kept hating myself what could
i have done how could i have stopped him
everybody said well go to counseling and
which counselor going to do talk [ __ ] to
you
yeah i'm sure you carry it with you
every day i do every day
every day
you know
it just do you do you feel like in some
ways it was selfish of him yeah
yeah he took care of it he didn't love
me because if you really thought it out
yeah did he have [ __ ] do you have kids
no you didn't they were trying nobody
had you yeah
and that would have
stopped most people from doing it or at
least talking it out or something right
and he he didn't he just as i said he
come over for new year's
he left about one and when i found him
in the morning he had been dead four
hours
um
to find your own kid dead
and that ain't no joke
if he'd just
if he just left me a message telling me
why
that he didn't blame me
oh
yeah it might have been easier for you
to process
yeah it's just the question mark is so
hard to process to deal with it it is
it's an everyday thing i played it every
day
what did i do
wrong could i have stopped it
but you know it leaves it don't leave it
don't just leave your heart hurting
leave your guts
leave your guts
oh that's heavy
so sorry
yeah
trying to care for somebody now
no way i'd care for a dead cat before i
would a human being
you know
i really would yeah i would that's
that's funny
all right eli well thank you so much for
sharing yourself are you welcome
thank you very much i ain't gonna go out
there crying no no i'll give you
you